[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
heute mit niedrigen siri schönen guten
abend ihnen allen und auch heute wieder
bei mir für den sport ist kristin otto
mit einem bunten mix genannt dann
schauen wir jetzt auf das was wichtig
ist und wichtig wird
ende der nullzinspolitik um die
inflation zu bremsen will die
europäische zentralbank im juli die
zinsen erhöhen zum ersten mal seit elf
jahren
ermittlungen nach berliner todesfahrt
offenbar ist der täter psychisch krank
ein schwer verletztes opfer schwebt noch
immer in lebensgefahr
streit um verbrenner aus die auto
branche wehrt sich gegen die
entscheidung des eu parlaments ab 2035
nur noch elektroautos zuzulassen
seit vielen jahren keine zinsen aufs
ersparte und billige kredite daran haben
wir uns fast alle schon gewöhnt aber das
dürfte sich jetzt ändern die europäische
zentralbank hat bei ihrer tagung in
amsterdam beschlossen im juli den
leitzins um 0,25 prozentpunkte anzuheben
warum dieser schritt nach über einem
jahrzehnt ausgerechnet jetzt erfolg das
schauen wir uns jetzt mal gemeinsam an
seit 2008 hat die ezb den leitzins immer
wieder gesenkt 2016 lag dann bei null
prozent und blieb dort gut fürs wachstum
gut für gross schuldner wie den staat
das risiko dabei inflation seit letztem
jahr steigen die preise jahr rasant in
deutschland bis auf 7,9 prozent in
diesem mai die ezb hat jetzt reagiert
sehr spät meinen viele peter wagner dazu
alles wird teurer die verbraucher
stöhnen benzin und heizöl lebensmittel
um 8,1 prozent stärker noch als in
deutschland steigen die preise im
schnitt in der eurozone im mai die hohe
inflation beherrschendes thema bei der
sitzung der ezb einmal mehr musste
präsidentin lagarde die prognosen
verkünden hat in flaschen precious hat
der inflationsdruck hat sich ausgeweitet
und verstärkt unsere experten haben
deshalb ihre inflationsprognosen
deutlich nach oben korrigiert der
wichtigste beschluss heute die ezb kauft
ab juli keine neuen staatsanleihen mehr
die geldmenge wird also nicht weiter
aufgebläht und eine ankündigung
wir beabsichtigen bei unserer sitzung im
juli den leitzins um 0,25 prozentpunkte
anzuheben
ist sehr sehr hoch mit 8,1 prozent und
trotzdem hat die ezb heute noch nicht
ihre zinsen angehoben sondern die
entscheidung verschoben auf juli und
damit riskiert sie dass die
inflationserwartungen die inflations der
ängste der menschen dass die weiter
steigen und sich die inflation
verfestigt demnächst also
0,25 prozent zinsen statt 0 dürfen sich
sparer und anleger innen freuen wir
bekommen zwei höhere zinsen aber das
problem ist die inflation ist noch
schneller das heißt jeder zinsertrag
wird von der inflation mehr als
aufgefressen im juli wird der ezb rat
dann wieder in frankfurt erstmals seit
elf jahren eine zinserhöhung verkünden
zu spät und zu zaghaft sagen die meisten
fachleute
fragen wir nach bei stefanie bareth in
frankfurt an der börse stefanie das war
heute eine weitreichende entscheidung
der währungshüter
mit welchen konsequenzen
ja wie wir es eben gehört haben die ezb
muss sich den vorwurf gefallen lassen
dass sie zu spät kommt um die inflation
einzufangen und mit dem ende der ära des
billigen geldes hat sie künftig auch
keine munition mehr um die wirtschaft in
krisenzeiten zu stützen zudem drohen
sich die inflationären risiken zu
verfestigen denn energie und
lebensmittelpreise dürften vor dem
hintergrund der krise weiterhin hoch
bleiben und milliarden summen sind nötig
für die eu pläne zum schutz des klimas
sowie für rüstungsausgaben wichtigste
auftrag der europäischen zentralbank ist
die geldstabilität dazu war die
entscheidung heute nicht entschlossen
genug wie ökonomen heute an märkten für
verbraucher dagegen werden die bauzinsen
zwar weiter steigen sparer hingegen
müssen sich noch gedulden bis die zinsen
auf ihr erspartes sehen immerhin werden
immer mehr banken keine negativzinsen
mehr von kunden verlangen auch
festverzinsliche wertpapiere wie
staatsanleihen werden nun wieder
interessanter für anleger aktien dagegen
die verlieren an attraktivität weil
risikoreiche abzulesen heute am dax der
nach der ezb-entscheidung auf
tauchstation ging und am ende mit einem
minus von 1,7 prozent schloss ihr am
finanzmarkt da wurde die zinswende
verhalten aufgenommen zu homöopathisch
um eine echte trendwende in der
geldpolitik zu bewirken dann vielen dank
nach frankfurt stefanie barrot
einen tag nach der tödlichen autofahrt
in berlin mit einer toten und inzwischen
mehr als 30 verletzten sind neue details
bekannt polizei und staatsanwaltschaft
gehen weder von einer terrortat noch von
einem unfall aus sondern von einer
schweren psychischen erkrankung des
fahrers er soll jetzt in einer
psychiatrie untergebracht werden
stephanie heim die spuren der tat sind
noch gut sichtbar berlin city west am
tag danach hier starb eine lehrerin
viele ihrer schüler zum teil schwer
verletzt auch ihr kollege
bundesfamilienministerin paus berlins
polizeipräsident in und die bundes
innenministerin zeigen mitgefühl
ich bin hier um unsere tief empfundene
anteilnahme der bundesregierung
auszudrücken mit vor allen dingen den
angehörigen der getöteten lehrerinnen
und den vielen verletzten wir wünschen
den verletzten schülerinnen und schülern
und den anderen verletzten passanten
alles erdenklich gute auch heute noch
bleibt unklar warum der täter mit dem
kleinwagen in die personen gerast weiter
gefahren und schließlich in ein geschäft
gekracht ist mord und versuchten mord
wirft die staatsanwaltschaft dem mann
denn noch am tatort festgenommen wurde
jetzt vor und spricht von seinen bekannt
gewordenen psychischen problemen
insofern spricht recht viel für eine
paranoide schizophrenie was ist
jedenfalls nicht gibt sind anhaltspunkte
für irgendeine art von terroristischem
hintergrund bei dem ganzen geschehen
aber
eben auch ein unfall wird sich vor
diesem hintergrund ausschließen lassen
trauer derweil in bad arolsen hier kommt
die klasse her viele menschen in der
stadt tief bewegt es werden schwere und
traurige tage erwarten
dass die nachricht die uns gestern hier
ereilt hat und worüber wir dann
gewissheit haben erfahren haben wir es
dann hat bad arolsen schwer getroffen
ich habe das in allen gesprächen die
führen konnte
erfahren in der täter soll in der
psychiatrie untergebracht werden der
lehrer ist laut staatsanwaltschaft auch
heute noch in lebensgefahr
das hat es seit kriegsausbruch noch
nicht gegeben todesurteile gegen drei
ausländische kämpfer die für die ukraine
in den krieg zogen verhängt in der
russisch kontrollierten ost ukraine
dort sind es die entscheidenden stunden
vor allem in der strategisch wichtigen
stadt zero dann jetzt es sei eine der
schwersten schlachten seit kriegsbeginn
so ukraine präsident seelands gehen
christoph distel berichtet
sekunden vor dem einschlag
erst eine streubombe staub wirbelt auf
während draußen weitere bomben
explodieren ukrainische soldaten halten
hier im nordwesten des dollars die
stellung erleichterung als der staub
sich liegt keiner verletzt doch für
einen jungen freiwilligen ist dieser
soldatenalltag zu viel
eigentlich kam ich hier um zu kämpfen
aber jetzt sehe ich das ist nichts für
mich
von dieser stellung in vancouver aus
rund 80 kilometer weiter östlich ist
alles wohl noch schlimmer dort liegt
servetto donetzk die schwer umkämpfte
stadt in der es für russen und ukrainer
gerade um so vieles geht
das ist ein sehr brutaler kampf
vielleicht der schwierigste in diesem
ganzen krieg
hier wird über das schicksal unseres don
was entschieden
bilder von diesem krieg im krieg gibt es
kaum unklar was in sedo netz gerade
passiert erst heißt es russische truppen
hätten im häuserkampf die ukrainischen
soldaten bis ins industriegebiet
abgedrängt dann beide seiten hätten sich
zurückgezogen russische
artilleriegeschosse jetzt ein
menschenleeres stadtzentrum
der bürgermeister spricht von 10.000
zivilisten die noch irgendwo in der
stadt fest dessen eine evakuierung sei
nicht mehr möglich sagt er
und der zuständige regionalgouverneure
gibt sich im gespräch mit dem zdf
kämpferisch
geben sie uns mehrfach raketenwerfer mit
reichweite damit wir die russische
artillerie ausschalten können und unsere
soldaten werden es dann schon selbst
richten
gleichzeitig weiterhin süden im auftrag
russlands räumen arbeiter das besetzte
aber total kaputt geschossen mariupol
auf und melden schon 112 1000 kubikmeter
trümmer seien weg geräumt während
anderswo laufend neue trümmer dazu
kommen
ja und das ganze interview mit dem
gouverneur der umkämpften region lohans
gleich um 19.30 bei zdf heute live in
unserer app und auf unseren social media
kanäle
seit dem angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine
versucht die eu russische vermögenswerte
einzufrieren oder zu beschlagnahmen und
dazu gehören auch yachten willen und
konnten russischer oligarchen die
wiederum versuchen oft erfolgreich ihre
werte und besitztümer zu verschleiern
und zu verstecken wie die eu effektiver
und noch schlagkräftiger werden kann
dazu trafen sich heute die
justizminister in luxemburg
anne gellinek
die luxusyacht schade im toskanischen
hafen von marina di carrara im mai
verhindern italienische behörden in
letzter minute ihr auslaufen und
beschlagnahmen stattdessen das schiff
dass wladimir putin zugeschrieben wird
italiens anti mafia gesetze erlauben
dass geschätzter wert der yacht 650
millionen euro es ist ein verlockender
gedanke das russische oligarchen
vermögen für den wiederaufbau der
ukraine genutzt werden könnten das
rechtlich umzusetzen aber ist schwierig
man müsse zwischen staatlichem besitz
und privatvermögen unterscheiden mahnte
der deutsche justizminister bei privaten
gibt es die möglichkeit auch
vermögensgegenstände abzuschöpfen das
instrument kennen wir in deutschland das
setzt aber voraus dass ihnen dann im
wege auch eines ordentlichen
gerichtsverfahrens nachgewiesen wurde
dass sie
beispielsweise kriegsverbrechen oder der
illegalen kriegsführung beteiligt waren
die eu justizminister wollen deshalb
auch die umgehung von sanktionen
europaweit strafbar machen außerdem
müsse man überlegen ob man russische
vermögen wie in den usa auch ohne
verurteilung beschlagnahmen keine torte
von morgen versuchen die
rechtsstaatlichkeit in der eu zu fördern
und deshalb muss alles was wir tun mit
rechtsstaatlichen prinzipien vereinbar
seien auch die verschleierung von
besitzverhältnissen bei immobilien und
die hilfe von anwälten bei der umgehung
von sanktionen könnten dann strafbar
werden es ist der versuch russischer
oligarchen am wiederaufbau in der
ukraine zu beteiligen
doch das könnte symbolpolitik bleiben
denn die rechtlichen hürden sind hoch
iran treibt sein umstrittenes
atomprogramm offenbar weiter voran die
internationale atomenergiebehörde zeigt
sich alarmiert denn die regierung in
teheran habe dutzende
überwachungskameras abschalten lassen
gleichzeitig sollten neue zentrifugen
zur uran-anreicherung installiert werden
iran hat sich dazu bislang nicht
geäußert
da hat sich die eu einiges vorgenommen
für mehr klimaschutz sollen autos mit
verbrennungsmotor nach dem jüngsten
beschluss ab 2035 nicht mehr verkauft
werden dürfen zwar müssen die
mitgliedstaaten dem eu beschluss noch
zustimmen aber wenig überraschend gibt
es im autoland deutschland deutliche
kritik zu den reaktionen lothar becker
es ist keine einfache wende in der
europäischen verkehrspolitik das aus für
verbrennungsmotoren in neuwagen ab 2035
denn gerade die herstellung von motoren
ist ein äußerst lukrativer teil der
wertschöpfungskette für die
automobilbranche am prinzip
verbrennungsmotor festhalten will auch
fdp verkehrsminister wissing wir wollen
die transformation technologie offen
gestalten dazu gehört dass wir über 2035
hinaus verbrennungsmotoren zu lassen
wenn diese ausschließlich mit
synthetischen kraftstoffen klimaneutral
betrieben werden auch der adac wünscht
sich einen ausbau der evs technologie
noch gibt es aber keine anlagen um
kraftstoffe aus co2 und strom im
industriellen maßstab zu produzieren für
den adac wäre sehr wesentlich dass wir
eben auch für die rund 30 millionen pkw
mit verbrenner motor die 2030 noch im
markt sein werden auch eine option haben
zum klimaschutz beizutragen
dafür wären beimischungen von evs zu
fossilem kraftstoff ein wichtiger weg
gewesen alle großen hersteller haben
sich bereits entschieden setzen auf
elektrische antriebe
seit mehreren jahren wird massiv
investiert in den aufbau der produktion
von elektrofahrzeugen emissionsfreien
fahrzeugen wir sehen massive
investitionen in auch batterie und
batterie zehn fabriken in europa der
ausbau der ladesäulen in deutschland
fährt parallel hoch in 12 jahren sollte
die wende möglich sein hin zu
bezahlbaren elektroautos mit hohen
reichweiten und einer guten
ladeinfrastruktur
sommerzeit ist reisezeit die nachfrage
nach flügen ist groß aber den airlines
fehlt personal während der korona
pandemie hatten viele beschäftigte
nämlich die branche gewechselt allein
die lufthansa muss deshalb im juli 900
verbindungen in europa streichen
vorwiegend am wochenende auch die
konzerntochter euro wings streicht
hunderte flüge außerdem warnt die
reisebranche vor langen wartezeiten bei
passkontrollen und abfertigung mit den
folgen der korona pandemie kämpft auch
weiter die logistikbranche die
lieferketten sind seit monaten gestört
ein ausgangspunkt der lange lockdown in
shanghai in deutschland zeigt sich das
problem jetzt in der nordsee mit einem
gewaltigen stau von containerschiffen
und zu alldem streiken jetzt auch noch
die hafenarbeiter sven rie wir stecken
die pötte fest ein paar seemeilen vor
der einfahrt in die elbe ist derzeit das
wartezimmer des hamburger hafens rund
150000 container parken in der nordsee
insgesamt weltweit so die berechnungen
von experten hängen elf prozent des
globalen handels im schiffsstau fest das
macht sich in den läden bald stark
bemerkbar da kann es eben auch mal sagen
dass im discounter aktionswaren fehlen
das im baumarkt bestimmte regale leer
sind thomas wollen der leitet ein großes
logistikunternehmen im hamburger hafen
derzeit muss er viel improvisieren sein
lager fühlt sich unaufhaltsam die
schiffe fehlen um die ladung an bord zu
nehmen
wenn es dann einmal voll ist dann ist es
voll das kennt man wie beim fast der
letzte tropfen bringt es dann zum
überlaufen und dass sie bei uns auf
lager dann geht halt nichts mehr und der
streik heute macht die sache noch
schwieriger durch ebbe und flut werden
aus zwei bis drei stunden
arbeitsniederlegung zwölf stunden ohne
schiff die frauen und männer von den
terminals fordern eine anerkennung für
durch den es arbeiten in der pandemie
die leute hier im hafen haben während
der korona pandemie alles gegeben und
das geben sie noch immer bis an
belastungsgrenzen darüber hinaus und
sichern den aufrechterhalten
lieferketten für thomas wollen die beach
heißt der streik trotzdem noch mehr rote
balken bei den an lieferzeiten an den
terminals für die verbraucher heißt das
noch lange löchrige lieferketten der
wirklich großen schiffsstau aus richtung
china kommt erst noch
jetzt weiter mit dem sport und christin
bei der fußball-nationalmannschaft ist
ein spannung angesagt muss ja immer so
wenn ich eine coole idee mut zur ruhe
vor der reise nach ungarn zum dritten
nations league spiel in einer woche
könnt bundestrainer hansi flick seiner
mannschaft also eine kurze pause
freizeit statt training verschnaufen
stadt laufen im teamquartier in
herzogenaurach
jonas hofmann der einzige deutsche
torschütze gegen england nutzt den
freien tag für einen kleinen ausflug das
urteil einiger beobachter man habe bei
diesem eins zu eins zwar hübsch aber gar
nicht effektiv gespielt korrigiert der
dfb-direktor heute ein wenig hübsch
schon gar nicht effektiv finde ich auf
beiden seiten ein bisschen zu negativ
ich würde sagen er attraktiv und gut
aber noch nicht effektiv genug
fehlen wird in ungarn definitiv marco
reus der sich bei einer individuellen
einheit nach dem england spiel einen
muskelfaserriss im rechten oberschenkel
zugezogen hat morgen vormittag wird es
hier auf dem trainingsplatz wieder
deutlich lebhafter zugehen ehe die
mannschaft dann am abend nach budapest
fliegt
handballer helfen handballern und so
wird in der kommenden saison der
ukrainische meister motor saborio als
gastverein in der zweiten bundesliga
spielen dafür sprach sich eine deutliche
mehrheit der deutschen vereine aus in
der ukraine ist der spielbetrieb wegen
des krieges ausgesetzt und das playoff
finale um die deutsche
basketball-meisterschaft ist komplett
nach alba berlin qualifizierte sich auch
bayern münchen durch den sieg im
entscheidenden fünften spiel gegen die
baskets bonn
bei uns ehren präsident uli hoeneß ist
erleichtert das team von trainer andreas
kirche ist nach zwei heimniederlagen
hier in weiß im entscheidungsspiel auf
der höhe zwar verspielen sie anfangs
einen klaren vorsprung gegen bonn die
mit paco jackson cartwright und seine 25
punkten den besten werfer haben doch vor
allem die 18 zähler von nick weinberg
verhelfen den bayern zum 87 zu 74 sieht
schon am freitag beginnt für sie in
berlin die finalserie im letzten jahr
hatten die bayern da gegen alba berlin
das nachsehen
finalserie best of five drei siege
meister leichter gesagt als getan
vielen dank christian john
basketballkorb drängt auf drei meter 5
höhe wir gehen jetzt ein bisschen höher
mehr als 100 jahre nach ihrer ausrottung
sind die bartgeier zurück in deutschland
nach der premiere im letzten jahr wurden
heute in bayern wieder zwei vögel
ausgewildert dagmar und recker zwei
weibchen die beiden schlüpften vor rund
drei monaten in spanien und heute
bezogen sich im nationalpark
berchtesgaden in etwa 1300 metern höhe
ihr neues zuhause nach etwa vier wochen
werden dagmar und recker zum ersten mal
das nest verlassen dann sind die flügel
mich stark
stark ist auch das was das wetter
bereithält ab morgen wird sonniger und
wärmer mehr hat gleich katja horneffer
das heute journal mit marietta slomka um
21 uhr 55 wir von heute 19 team sagen
danke fürs zuschauen und freuen uns wenn
sie morgen wieder dabei sind für sie
noch einen entspannten abend
[Musik]
guten abend der juni sommer schaukelt
einfach so vor sich hin heute überquerte
uns die kaltfront von tief nana und das
-hoch hier über südfrankreich bringt uns
zum wochenende viel sonnenschein und
auch wärme in süddeutschland da kratzen
die werte an der 30 grad marke heute
nacht fällt im alpenvorland und auch im
bayerischen wald noch etwas regen sonst
es ist häufig nur locker bewölkt oder
sogar klar und es bildet sich auch mal
nebel die temperaturen sinken auf werte
zwischen 13 und 6 grad und steigen
morgen an der nordsee und am alpenrand
auf 19 grad sonst werden 20 bis 25 grad
erreicht und es wird hier in der lausitz
oder auch im südlichen brandenburg mit
26 grad am wärmsten
das wird ein sehr freundlicher freitag
häufig mit sonnenschein vormittags kann
es hier wieder bayern noch etwas regnen
und nachmittags sind dann einzelne
regenschauer in den westlichen
mittelgebirgen nicht ganz ausgeschlossen
das wochenende wird sehr sommerlich und
nur über norddeutschland ziehen ab und
zu mal kleinere regenschauer hinweg die
temperaturen steigen auf 19 bis 30 grad
und erst die neue woche startet mit dem
wechselhaften wetter ich wünsche dir
noch einen schönen abend